and I have one thing in common
we are very disenchanted with the human
experiment the difference is I'm an
optimist and Logan is a pessimist and
he's a misanthrope I'm not a misanthrope
because my job is to understand and
really like Humanity you say he does
villainous things but he's not a villain
what does that mean
I don't think he's a villain I think
he's he's as human as the rest of us but
he has incredible shortcomings the key
to Logan is that as Jesse said to me
very early on because I was saying the
first question I asked me does he love
his children
this man who's behaved so extraordinary
that's the point he loves his children
and once you have that once you know
that that's what Logan is then it's
what's happening is incredibly painful
and Incredibly difficult for Logan
though he doesn't go anywhere near there
that's why it's a beautifully written
character and it's full of mystery so we
don't always know what's going on which
I love I love that aspect so the
audience are not being fed stuff they're
having to just make assumptions and
sometimes the audience make the wrong
assumption because those kids can be
right pens in the ass you think you
think
all he's trying to do is find a success
everybody's business that's all the guys
trying to do
Alan Rock has starred in the series
since 2018 he plays Conroy the oldest of
the Roy siblings who's pursuing a long
shot presidential run Alan Ruckus here
joining us now welcome good morning good
morning yeah your chances don't look so
good Mr President leverage
that's not coming in like the one for
set yeah it's something that's like a
million people I do love that attitude
which is so much on display in the show
um but how do you feel about the fact
that the show is coming to an end I'm
not ready Alan none of us are well
neither am I uh yes I made friends for
life on this show
um
and uh yeah it's bittersweet really
happy to have been a part of this thing
yeah one of the nicest uh
sort of periods of my career absolutely
the best writers I've ever worked with
fabulous cast great directors everything
the designers everything every member of
the cast and crew
has that quality of yes and yes like can
you do this yes and I was thinking about
this other thing and everybody adds
their special touch to it and that's why
the show is so good the use of the
f-bombs too in addition to Great writing
but the way that they use the f-bombs
and the way that they well specifically
Brian Cox but everybody is yeah yeah
it's very pervasive but now that is all
also also taking on a life of its own
too that I think is sort of fun to watch
do you yes I do I I don't trust people
that don't curse you know you don't as
long as you have an expansive vocabulary
I think you know the occasional F-bomb
is is highly approved and if you and if
you wield it well more power to you
that's called good writing uh okay so uh
I want to know if you can share the
extent you can whether you think fans
will be satisfied with the ending which
I imagine you know well at this point I
think it's the best season we've done I
know that's that's a bold statement but
I really do think it's the best season
we've done I love that you said you've
made friends for life that you've made
friends for life on this show I have
done on a few things I've done I did a
show years ago called Spin City I made
friends for life Stuart I remember yeah
so uh all those guys Barry Bostwick
Michael Boatman Richard kind everybody
we're still pals are there I'm sorry oh
go ahead no I got nothing
Alan you always have something this is
always a news guy question but like are
there real-life politicians that you as
an actor looked at and Drew inspiration
from to play uh your character running
for office
honor is so um sort of divorced from
reality yeah that I mean I mean some
would say there are politicians out
there who also are you know I think I'm
he's not very current he doesn't have a
lot of current sort of Heroes I think I
mean he Harkens back to Lincoln and and
models himself very much I mean his
fascination with Napoleon yeah yes I
mean nothing sort of current but but
people from the past he admires greatly
yeah we're very very happy for you very
happy yeah congratulations and it wasn't
just Ferris I loved you in Young Guns I
loved you in Spin City and I love you in
success
that's right